next one though oh this one's also hot
dear near and dear to our heart best
argument
so this time it's a two-sided rant yeah
essentially yeah that is technically an
opposing two-sided rant uh yeah
oh my god uh how many arguments do we
have this year um a lot and we continue
doing so let's see what the nominations
are uh the great chicken debate oh that
was this year wasn't it oh my god that
feels like an eternity that was in the
studio holy yeah that was like right
when we moved i was like the week after
we moved in like i think and we're just
like can we top any of the arguments
season one and then we immediately come
in with like the great chicken debate
i i want to clarify people
to this day still think i don't eat
bone-in chicken i do i just prefer
boneless yeah yeah still a clown yeah
still a clown yeah i like i like boning
chicken i just prefer bone out i'm glad
i'm sitting on this side right i'm glad
i'm saying i hang out with people who
like watch trash taste sometimes like i
met them they'll be like oh you sure
you're okay eating that bone bone and
chicken i'm like i'm like what the [ __ ]
yes good [ __ ] i would just prefer if
there was no bone exactly good you
deserve that you deserve it you both
deserve that you both shut them
i'm so curious just just see how we cut
this together boundless boneless fries
i'm a boneless kind of guy man i'm a
boneless get get that bone out of there
if i can't eat it get it out of my face
sometimes i just don't want to go
through the process of being like a
[ __ ] animal and tearing this [ __ ]
from limb
i'm not i just know it's nice
better
you're like
what are you talking about
this is like one of the few times where
all three of us are talking at the same
time
i just i just realized how much of a
karen i sounded there oh you are a karen
it tastes better
it tastes
better because it does i was just like
you guys have made me do something i've
never done before which is go for
carrots
i was like call the manager mailing get
here right now all right and then we
also have obviously the great pizza
debate
i mean this this is another like two
versus yeah argument right
uh and then connor thinks he definitely
bought a neighbor oh this okay so the
last two are from the the figure special
which there were certainly a lot of
crowning arguments on yeah yeah yeah and
then all among us have seen true
that was one of my favorite arguments i
think
i just love how angry connie got yeah
i'm like i'm like you do realize you're
fuming over [ __ ] among us right now
i realized all of these arguments are
like me
having to argue
all of these are you being difficult i'm
not being difficult you're on my side
for this one what are you talking about
i was in the middle [ __ ] no oh you
were doing that like yeah bro what are
you italy in world war two
i was average i was average chicken
enjoyer right there i was like i can go
both bro
i'm not letting you get away with that
joey i am not late
because we can't let me off the hook
joey comes in because like this is this
isn't even even like in the worst food
takes right because it was so
overshadowed by the rest of the chicken
debate that i remember being like bone
and chicken the same and like joey was
like no all chicken is the same and it's
like that just like
like the [ __ ] argument yeah and then
he just like stepped out
he he stepped out i was like it's the
same all right
i don't think the chicken one will win
i think the chicken one is the most
iconic definitely ah and there's a
lasting impact to this and i'm still
we're still arguing it to this day like
honestly like great pizza debate i'm
like whatever connor can think what he
thinks like he's just like wrong you
guys are just wrong in the great chicken
debate like you guys are just wrong oh
yeah whatever whatever you're just just
wrong i'm sorry all right let's find out
then the best argument of joshua's 2022
is
the great chicken debate naturally
naturally
not not even surprised by that i
shouldn't even be close that shouldn't
even be close oh it's not sorted to this
day um i'm still not happy about the
results the arguments we'll guess it won
by like 50 plus or something
50.6 yeah yes yeah not even surprising
do you know my favorite moment of this
argument is uh at the end me and connor
were just like we we handshook about
both being clowns yeah and then we were
immediately afterwards go back into
arguing
it's like you shook hands and then it
was like i still hate you
you're still wrong though that's not
wrong though [ __ ] you dude
all right what's next up
uh next up is
um so as you know with trash taste we
have a lot of food takes and we have a
lot of
bad food so the next award
is to reward our worst food takes i mean
to be honest i don't even have to see
the nominations you know who's on this i
know there's one there's all bread
tasters okay i would just have to say
that obviously that was a bad food take
but there are there have been some
outrageous food takes this year well
let's let's see let's see what the
nomination is like
we are truly living up to our names here
all right so cereal is better with our
milk
okay i stopped by that ninety percent of
bread tastes the same uh all rice tastes
the same that's joey that was just me
miss phrasing what i was trying to say
yeah
all japanese rice tastes the same i can
obviously tell difference between
[ __ ] japanese rice and basmati rice
okay like i'm not that dead in the
tongue uh new york pizza is better than
snowballs
no that was that's pretty no what uh
also your canned tuna tastes better than
fresh tuna that's nothing
like it's like you don't even that
doesn't even deserve a clip man that
doesn't even deserve a clip
i i think it has a taste to it
that was so bad very so bad and then
chewy steak is like meat flavored that
was melon
yeah that just came out of nowhere i was
just like you said what
okay so there's two gaunt two connor one
me one mailing well i know who's going
to win congratulations gantt on your
award yeah i'm just saying it to say
right now just say it right now what is
the worst food take is
new york pizza is nice [ __ ] bread
like i saw connor's jaw literally drop
for a second there i was like i was like
no
all the europeans missed this one
that's for sure
all right what how much did it win by
uh forty eight point nine percent holy
[ __ ]
[ __ ] out second and third out of
curiosity cereal is better without milk
came in second
congratulations on having the worst food
doubles
that's the legitimacy i stand by that i
stand by that cereal is better without
the milk third was
chewy steak is like meat flavored gum
wow we weren't even in the trap we
weren't even in this awesome food takes
a good day hell yeah thanks guys
thank you viewers
all right what's the next one connor
next up is you know you've heard the
worst food takes what about the best
poop man
um we talk about poop a lot i don't know
how i don't know how i'm surprised we
have a category for this but apparently
we do what was that what was the tagline
you used to say for trash taste again
the podcast where we talk about food
anime and uh food poop and occasionally
anime yeah yeah
did i say that yeah that was you how did
you remember that i don't know because
it just stuck by me i'm like it's so
avid it's true it's true so what are the
nominations yes uh oh yeah me sniffing
cat poop in a sock yeah that's just
meleen getting me there yeah yeah we got
have you ever coughed his [ __ ] at the
same time that's also me
that's like best out of context moment
as well
can we see can we can we see these clips
actually i want to see these guys
yeah yeah yeah you have a very
suspicious sock
melon put cash [ __ ] in that
i sword [ __ ] believe it i couldn't
[ __ ] believe it
i got paid to sniff cat [ __ ] she brought
cat [ __ ] from her house to the office
yeah yeah yeah train
public transport that's what i was more
like offended about the fact that you
would do that
yeah
joey
i don't even know why you said this have
you ever coughed and [ __ ] at the same
time no
no
we're not talking about [ __ ] yet
yeah
[Laughter]
talks about pooping in video games this
is to do with ark i believe oh yeah yeah
yeah play this clip
really famous for pooping it really is
just google arkansas
you are you sure ark is famous for
pooping or are you trying to make it
famous are you trying to make a face
google it right now ark poop i've just
seen compilations of v tubers reacting
to dinosaurs pooping an arc and they
just like lose their mind what
compilation yeah this is like uh like a
chef mac moment where we were just like
we did not like
tell her to talk start talking about
poop we tried our best to not talk about
poop because we had to guess this was
like they knew the assignment yeah yeah
yeah yeah right
uh and then we also have why god spends
30 minutes on the toilet you actually
genuinely take 30 minutes of [ __ ] we get
to the point in this office where i
legitimately go where's god yeah we go
and we realize he's been gone for 30
minutes did he go to the shops or
something no he's taking a [ __ ] are you
performing like alchemy in there like
why is it taking so long
they didn't show it in this clip but
yeah this pathway god's like i just
don't feel satisfied until i'm
completely empty
i still stand by that man it's just like
you need once you go poop you need to
get it all out otherwise why are you
sitting down you know why are you
sitting down i'm guessing this is the
origin of the poop i i guess
okay we found it out let's play it so
it's like this right yeah right i'm like
okay close the lid flush and then i do
this while it's flashing but your pants
are down right
no well that's the exact same thing as
i'm getting up i kind of like pull it up
to the point of like like it's there but
i just got to zip it up and do the belt
you know you understand what i mean you
understand what i mean right no
why was this a conversation i i remember
it was the day before we had this
episode i had this thing where the guy
uh
like flushed the toilet and then
immediately left the toilet and i
thought ha that guy must have done
everything and then flushed the toilet
and immediately walked out
i flush the toilet the moment i stand up
right yeah yeah yeah yeah i was just
like i wonder if i'm the same so i guess
that's why i came back oh yeah yeah that
was a pretty deep conversation regarding
poop because i remember we had like like
a 30 minute conversation just breaking
down poop technique i remember like 15
minutes of talking about like do you
wipe from the front or from the back oh
it was like
well let's find out who the winner is oh
who do you want to win
i want me sniffing captain jerry's
sniffing yeah
both of them are joey like have you
cough and [ __ ] at the same time such a
[ __ ] good clipper
well the winner is
joey sniffs
you know i'll [ __ ] say that
i'm proud of that one well deserved well
deserved i did it for the boys thank you
very much
for possibly like
i i think making the most
unintentionally memorable ad read that
we've ever done
because that wasn't ad read yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm sure lavoy
was thrown with that one uh what were
the percentages
i'm sorry
cat [ __ ] one with 39 percent of the vote
oh damn hell yeah and uh joey coughing
and [ __ ] one with 20 uh came in
second with 21.9 percent of them
i'll say that